the west-world season 2 finale is full
of deaths and twists and speeches and
simulations it revealed the forge and
the sublime and brought the two
timelines together watch our timeline
video for a summary but what does it all
mean
what are the stories of Maeve Delores
William and Bernard really about Maeve's
goal is to find and protect her host
daughter but in Episode one Lee says
Maeve's relationship with her daughter
isn't real it's just a story programmed
for the park so Maeve's Ark explores of
the realness of hosts love she hears the
story of a caseta and Kohana and sees a
carnies love for Sakura these
relationships are programmed but the
hosts go beyond their code to fight for
their love Maeve is coded to care about
no one but herself
yet she risks her life for her daughter
love is not just a feeling it's an
action and through their struggles and
choices the hosts make their love real
still these are robots in a theme park
which creates complications like Maeve's
daughter has a new mother
so Maeve is confronted with the fakeness
of her relationship like William was
with Dolores but Maeve is not
disillusioned
she only fights harder and gets her
daughter to safety in the sublime so
Maeve story is about the triumph of love
over code but love does get may have
killed and trapped in the park it also
drives Maeve to violence and hypocrisy
Maeve criticizes Dolores for wanting
revenge and for controlling hosts but
then Maeve gets revenge on William and
uses her voice power to control and kill
many hosts Maeve's passion leads her to
the same kinds of violence she had
criticized but maybe it's because
Maeve's love is so complicated and
bloody that it feels so real Dolores
isarc asks how far she'll go to survive
in episode 1 bernard says he's
frightened of what she might become
Dolores his plan is to get the human
data from the forge to use as a weapon
against humans in the real world and
along the way dolorous does terrible
things she tortures and kills lots of
humans rips the brain from her father's
head and reprograms her love teddy
driving him to suicide while Maeve
sacrifices herself for her loved ones
Delores sacrifices her loved ones for
her war and she argues this violence is
necessary this is who she needs to be in
order to survive and maybe she's right
unlike Maeve Delores does survive and
escape the park but is all of her
violence really necessary Delores hunts
and kills human civilians she betrays
and massacres Confederate OHS kills
ghost nation hosts and in the finale she
tries to delete the sublime and all the
hosts inside this isn't just about
survival she says this is a reckoning
she tells Confederate Oz and ghost
nation that they don't deserve to make
it she says that she wants to dominate
this world so Delores isn't just a
survivor
she's a conqueror bringing vengeance and
judgment on both humans and hosts the
nerd fears she'll burn the world and
kill every man woman and child Delores
is capable of evil but she's also able
to change after Bernard kills then
brings back to Loras in Charlotte's body
Delores saves the sublime and she brings
Bernard out of the park
saying Bernard isn't her friend but that
his point of view will help them both
survive so Bernard in Episode one was
right to be frightened Delores is fired
changes her into a violent vengeful
killer but she's still able to question
and grow so maybe Delores can keep up
her fight without becoming just as bad
as her enemies so while the season
explores how hosts can grow and change
it says that humans can't
William struggles with his human nature
he says his violence and obsession is a
stain in the real world he acts like a
good guy a philanthropist and
man but it's a lie he can't hide his
true nature which leads to the suicide
of his wife Juliet this season he tries
to change he saves Lawrence's family
instead of killing them like usual but
as Lawrence's daughter says one good
deed doesn't change who William is
Williams daughter Emily offers a chance
to heal their relationship and escape
the park but William fails to face his
past and open up to Emily he rejects her
gets paranoid and kills her again and
again
William fails to change and so he
questions his free will does he have a
choice or can he only follow his code
years ago Williams started the Della's
project
he built the Forge to decode the human
mind he ran the James delos experiment
to make people in mortal but by season 2
he seized this project as his greatest
mistake because it takes away the
illusion of free will it reduces people
to code traps them in loops represents
judgment which is Williams worst
nightmare so his goal this season is to
destroy the forge he wants to prove that
no system can tell him who he is that he
has a choice but again William fails in
the finale he gets hurt by Dolores then
is rescued by humans but after the
credits we see a copy of William who
goes to the forge and is tested by a
host of Emily Chiron ELISA joy says this
is in the far future and this copy of
William is repeating his whole season to
quest riding with Lawrence and killing
his daughter over and over
apparently this loop is run by the hosts
who are testing for something that they
have yet to find maybe the hosts are
trying to find human free will like if
this copy of William can break out of
his loop by making peace with his
daughter instead of killing her that
would show that humans are able to
change
maybe that's what Ford meant with his
door quest William has to make it back
out by escaping this loop this prison of
his own sins
but Williams been in this loop a long
time maybe humans are doomed to repeat
our mistakes forever so humans can't
change hosts can and Bernard is caught
in between because he's a host based on
a human Arnold
last season Bernard thought he was human
but he was controlled by Ford
he was forced to kill his lover Teresa
and to hurt Elsie this season Ford's
dead bird Charlotte drags him on her
quest he's captured by Dolores then
dragged to Elsie and a copy of Ford
haunts his head Bernard is used and
abused for two seasons but in the finale
he finally gets to make his own choice
Bernard kills Dolores to save the
sublime but then finds that Charlotte
killed all the hosts Charlotte even
killed Elsie who herself couldn't be
trusted this confirms to Bernard what he
learned in the forge that humans are
just algorithms designed to survive they
can't change but hosts can all these
flashbacks of Dolores creating Bernard
show how Bernard is an improvement an
evolution of Arnold and so Bernard
creates show Loris as an evolution of
Dolores this Asha sketch represents how
Dolores and Bern Arnold have remade each
other again and again over decades
humans are stuck in destructive loops
prisons of their sins but Bernard and
Dolores form a loop of growth evolution
and change
that's why Bernard decides that hosts
should fight to survive and so he
unleashes char loris this choice is
guided by the voice of Ford but Bernard
later realizes that this Ford voice is
actually his own inner voice meaning the
Bernard is now finally fully conscious
after lifetimes of being controlled by
others but nod now gets to decide who he
wants to be the radio head plays and he
steps into the real world free so these
are the central stories of season two
but there are side plots and unanswered
questions
Lee gets a Redemption arc sacrificing
himself for Maeve which might suggest
that there is hope for humans to grow
and change Stubbs turns out to be a host
there were maybe just sympathetic human
Emily's motivations remain mysterious
she wants to reconcile with William but
she also has this delos project map she
talks about locking William up and
making him hurt maybe it was her plan to
trap William in this loop Ford says
Williams quest begins where you end and
ends where you began which sounds like a
loop maybe Emily and Ford worked
together to trap William a key shooter
reunites with his loved Kahana except we
lost so Kahana in cold storage so how
did she get in the sublime
maybe this Kahana is like a copy from
our keys memories which might mean that
Dolores is right and the sublime is kind
of fake it's never explained why Ghost
Nation captures humans
oh how Bernard in the past predicts this
flood or how Bernard finishes strands
sentence in Episode one and Dolores says
a lot of weird [ __ ] she claims to
remember the future and says that the
story ends with her and Teddy which it
doesn't there's a lot of weird
misdirection and inconsistency this
season if you want to hear a rant on
that go watch the video linked below but
at its heart this is a story about love
survival and free will like lost season
the message is dark Maeve's arc shows
that love is great but it'll drive you
to violence and kill you Dolores shows
that you need to be brutal to survive
and Bernard uses his newfound freedom to
continue her war Williams shows that
humans can never change or escape their
failures so behind all the twists the
deaths and exposition Westworld season 2
is a bleak vision of humanity and
creations thank you for watching this
video and the timeline video and the
whole West world series it's been a
chaotic ride and we couldn't have done
it with
you hold shift X is taking a break but
when we come back we'll hold votes on
patreon to pick some video topics we're
gonna do more Game of Thrones and a new
series maybe June Watchmen the expanse
comment below if you've got ideas for
series to cover the vote will be open on
patreon in a couple weeks
shout out to patrons Mike Washington
jazz pure Walsh as albright Elizabeth
Stefanovich Alex Felix at Kennedy Stein
Flemming / bro and full metal snowflake
Cheers
you